ils lui ont donné des coups de poing au
sol comme en réseau les faits dans un
ballon de foot c'est écrit noir sur
blanc
[Musique]
ce fameux 5 juillet ans c'est le bel
matin tous les deux de très bonne heure
était 6h30 je me rappellerai toujours
parce qu'on n'arrive pas dans mes livres
j'ai chopé que j'ai beau commencer tôt
et commence à 12h30 ce jour là donc il
est parti vers 11h45 et les participants
s'est fait une grosse bise ou à tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure et puis vers
18h sortie du jardin j'étais prendre ma
douche on s'est envoyé des textos tous
les deux à 18h56 je les ai toujours dans
mon téléphone il était au leclerc
l'arrêt de bus en haut là bas et un gros
bisou à tout à l'heure
et dix minutes après on me l'a tué
et
18h56 d'innover recettes ils ont
commencé à le massacre
et après donc moi j'étais là
je rate à la télé puis je monte les
fonds ne sont jamais vue d'acheter à
monter les fraudes et puis je vois un
numéro il m'appelle il ya le magic ou
hero ces yoyos
là je salue le yom ce moment je n'ai pas
réalisé et me dit tu es tout seul et
puis après là je commençais à réfléchir
un médiateur ils m'appellent il a
sûrement besoin par la flip pourquoi il
appelle pas philippe en fait puisque
c'est un collègue lui
et il me dit qu'il s'est passé quelque
chose
je viens de chercher mais j'ai dit mais
qu'est il se dit qu'est ce qu'il ya et
midi s'est passé quelque chose dans la
voiture j'ai harcelé à yoyo dans la
voiture je vais harcelés et et savez il
savait sauf qu'il n'a pas pu le dire
quand je suis arrivé au bureau des
urgences
il y avait la dame et il y avait un
médecin du samu qui était de dos et je
dis bon soir sjps madame guillaume mon
époux est chez vous et quand j'ai dit
mon guillot le médecin s'est retourné il
a dit ça je le revois mais là quand
c'était hier et il a dit au téléphone je
te rappelle il a accroché et je lui ai
dit je veux voir philippe je vois mon
des poules de suite je vous le voir je
vois il me dit vous pouvez pas juger
pourquoi je peux pas le voir et me dit
le bloc le rapport
est celui développé de quoi il m'a dit
de la tête et là
là ça s'est confirmé ce que j'avais
ressenti s'est confirmée
et m'a dit c'est très grave voilà et là
je sors surveille au delà
je sais je comprenais rien quoi je
comprenais rien n'est pas ce qu'il ya et
je rentrais les filles étaient assises
comme tendu là pour tout ce sont
regrettés comme ça et je leur ai dit
papa était entre la vie la mort
et là ils ont
sorti la cave les trois savais pas quoi
faire
les prenant les bras les leurs tirs
attendez attendez bon ben voilà on va
aller le voir tout à l'heure et tout va
pour cet hymne dramatique
n'était soi respiratory cell toutes ces
fonctions vitales étaient détruites il
avait un truc bleu noir je passe te
rappelles jaune gonfler les tuyaux qui
rentrait la peine de piqûres qui
rentrent ici à la tempe comme produit
sur moi enfin perfusion vaches à faire
le respirateur la langue d'un petit bout
de la glace en fait j'ai su les détails
le lendemain par lettre par la
conférence de presse du procureur de la
république à la télé
parce qu'il a dit violence extrême coup
de pied dans la tête la tête cible et il
a dit il ya un témoin qui dit il lui ont
donné des coups de poing au sol
commanderie aurait fait dans un ballon
de foot c'est écrit dans sur blanc on
parle du meurtre a dit de marseille sauf
que ça démarre à 14 entre les deux
futurs meurtrier ils sont mis à 14h30
ch'ti philippe robé le rôle du tram à
balijon ils voulaient monter dans le bus
sans prendre de ticket sans payer
philippe l'habitation à son siège il
était à la porte de devant ils voulaient
monter et il ya un témoignage ce jour-là
et philippe ne le vous prenez un ticket
vous n'allez pas comme peut-être vous a
pas commence à me faire chier au pr
n'indiquer vous monter dans le bus c'est
tout il a insulté il est sorti de sa
cabine pour les aider à prendre un
ticket à la borne sur le trottoir il ya
une photo d'un de ces instructions qui
montre mon époux en train d'aider celui
qui va lui ôter la vie cinq ans après
donc philippe les amener à biarritz
puisque ça lui va bien
ils sont remontés dans le bus le soir
sauf qu'ils étaient plus deux étaient
quatre et les témoins disent qu'ils le
provoquer du fond du bus arrive à
balijon il est sorti et
easy à une cliente qui étaient là et
enfin il ne dit pas il dit fort philippe
bon là ça peut plus continuer comme ça
ça va pas le faire on le voit ypersele
pendant un bon moment et devant lui il a
des bêtes féroces qui pond comme ça en
plus dans le tram les mecs qui sont sur
la marche derrière est donc sans odeur
et philippe est en état passe la marche
est un peu plus bas il est écrit noir
sur blanc d'un des meurtriers
on va te démonter à l'extérieur on va te
finir c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans
c'est ce qu'il a dit vous l'avez
ailleurs et terminer mon époux se relève
pour aller se protéger dans son bus et
on est venu l'achever on est venu lui
donner un uppercut dans les coups de
poing c'est pas juste un coup de poing
qui l'a fait chuter au sol et le sol
actuel époux non non ça c'est ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'a dit le
médecin légiste à sa devenir deuxième
expertise la phase 2 c'est à dire le
coup de poing qui a fait chuter
lourdement philippe au sol n'a été
possible que parce qu'il ya eu une phase
la requalification aujourd'hui n'est pas
juste ces violences en réunion ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner elle est complètement
contradictoire par rapport au dossier
d'instruction tout simplement il ya des
témoignages il ya des vidéos il ya des
mots qui prouve meurtre aggravé la
première qualification au départ du
parking
il rentre donc dans les bus
1990 il ya tout un travail est en fait
qui lui plaisait c'était d'être routier
la crau non plus si l'ampoulé plus qu il
est réélu un stade au waou les gens qui
sont irrespectueux les gens qui montent
dans le bus qui vous regardent qui vous
disent pas bonjour
c'est ici aussi tu te fasses pas révélé
des fois que viser loin tu payes gamins
nous sinon tu restes un dehors tu prends
pas le musée
voilà qu'aujourd'hui presque plus dur ça
aujourd'hui vous dites quelqu'un tu
payes le mec qui va vous voilà
c'est long de ma vie a été travaillé
très tôt à l'âge de 14 ans pouvoir
subvenir aux besoins de ses frères
soeurs et sa maman on n'est jamais parti
en vacances tous les deux jamais a
préféré travailler
avoir des enfants acheter une maison et
propriétaires et penser à nous après et
là on devait acheter un camping-car en
septembre 2020 donc et c'est là la
discussion qu'on a eue le dernier soir
quand on est et restera un bien
rythme-là premier voyage je ferai un
voyage immobile voulait m'amener me dit
jessica je vais t'emmener à ouessant
alors écoute moi bien je vais avec moi
je suis une femme du sud il nous faut la
plage le soleil et que je puisse me
baigner ou et ça je vais avoir froid non
ils vont on va aller au bout et ça s'il
te plaît me flambe allait jouer sans
se mettre dans le camping car à sa tête
et tout ça va être bien et après il m'a
dit non tu vas avoir leur caillavet des
émissions avant il y avait le truc sur
l'a3 la des racines et des ailes dans la
sacoche pas quoi sur roues est sain il
était assis sur la table les pieds sur
la chaise comme ça et moi j'avais pris
la fuite et la la photo de la télé de
ouessant et la photo de lui en ai vu les
pare brise en jeu la vie bon le samedi
soir je l'avais dit ok on ira le premier
truc en ira aux usa je l'aï dit d'accord
moi on m'a offert la médaille fait en
enfer pour philippaerts dont la médaille
du courage du dévouement mais ne me
ferez pas la médaille du courage et de
dévouement aux frais mois une justice
etc plaire c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça
[Musique]